how do you go from the idea stage to the
actual execution to the final video
what's can you take me through like a
full process of like course we're
talking about some crazy wild ideas
today how do you go from that to a final
video where you click publish well I
mean obviously first things first you
gotta figure out the idea and then it
just depends I mean pick any video you
can think of on my channel I can take
you through it
uh
well what about the in a circle you have
to stay in a circle for uh 400 Days yeah
so for that one step one one of the most
popular yeah that video did really well
yeah so we
um promise uh we have to this is where
you get really into the nuances of the
company because we have a lot of videos
going on you can't just in a vacuum be
like all right we're not doing anything
for 100 days we're only filming this so
Step One is we had to build an
independent crew that could actually do
that for 100 days that way everyone else
could keep working on the normal videos
and not just screw everything up yeah
um so step one you build that team okay
we got the team now what do we need well
to do this we need probably like 10
cameras at least rolling at all times so
uh we're probably gonna need to get a
trailer and hook up a bunch of storage
and stuff so to just carry out the sheer
volume of footage we're gonna have and
so get a trailer set up the cameras go
on the field paint a circle now we need
a house go buy a house bring it out
there uh and then it's like oh wait I
think it'd be funny if I brought the
house in on the intro if I yeah you know
find a crane that can lift up a house so
I can drive it in and drive it in the
intro and that's like an iterative
process where you're like okay this
would be funnier so this is not all up
front it's right yeah it's like your
ideally it would be but as you kind of
see things you get inspired and then you
think of more and more uh and then this
would be better with a crane yeah it'd
be better if I dropped out of the house
yeah that was crazy that you decided to
do that uh so Fearless in the kind of
crazy stuff you're willing to do exactly
what I'm a broken record but whatever
makes the best video possible yeah
that's that's all you you focus on okay
so uh what about the delegation of like
who gets to what are the cameraman like
the people operating the cameras what uh
who's responsible for different things
this is like a distributed process like
well that's where whoever the lead cam
would be on that video would just
decided that one because we shot over
100 days we didn't a lot of it was just
Sean and the guy who was in The Circle
just vlogging I'm just gave him a camera
yeah and he figured it out and then we'd
have like for him just set hours each
day that I can't remember would come so
if he had any content he needed extra
hands instead of just having someone on
standby 24 7. it made more sense to do
set hours nice
um and uh yeah it was it was hard but
you know explaining it in hindsight it
sounds so simple you know and I I guess
like the more because that one is
relatively simple I guess because it's a
low number of people yeah the hard part
about that is just the time like you
know I checked in on them so many
different days and it's like an hour
here two hours later three hours there
over a hundred days adds up to be a ton
of time and and even then like you know
if you have a 10 person crew you know
paying them daily rates for 100 days
that just all that adds up what about
like the 100 versus 100 100 uh adults
versus younger kids
what was uh what was uh bringing that to
life that seems like exceptionally
challenging yeah basically the thought
process was we did 100 kids or sorry 100
boys 100 girls yeah people loved it
honestly I didn't think they'd like it
as much as they did video did really
really well so the second I saw that
video was crushing I was like all right
we're doing it again but last time we
did it we did in our studio so we built
a a giant room put 100 girls in it
sounds bad when I explain it like this
and then a giant put 100 boys yeah and
we're like after 100 hours whichever
room has the most people give them half
a million dollars it's uh did well so
we're like all right we're gonna do it
again so we threw out all these
different ideas it was like 100 football
players versus 100 cheerleaders 100 this
100 that and uh 100 prisoners versus 100
cops just craziest ideas and we settled
on 100 Kids versus 100 adults
um and then the next step was like how
do we make it better the kids versus
adults are the sorry the boys versus
girls the first one we did was inside
and the problem was every time it was
night when we did these long time lapses
you couldn't see the Sun go up and down
so we're like okay this time I want to
do it outside that's why the cubes are
outside
um and instead of doing circles we want
to make them cubes and then you know as
figuring out do we want that yeah
there's just those videos came up at
least today as ones that are like really
complicated in terms of the audio in
terms of how yeah yeah that's the
problem we had a lot of audio issues
because uh in the first one we didn't
have a roof on it the second one there
was a roof so there's a lot of Reverb
which then in editing made it brutal
like half the shots weren't usable and
it really screwed us over so we had to
do a lot of frankensteining in the
editing to make up for basically my
ignorance